we've been covering the growing Civil
War so to speak between the anti-trump
and pro-trump Republican party but the
anti-trump so-called anti-trump
Republican party is often people who
were never into Trump we are now seeing
something different as a result of
Donald Trump making really mild milk
toast uncontroversial statements about
the vaccines are pretty good at keeping
you out of the hospital for covet a
bunch of actual former trumpists have
turned on Donald Trump and some are even
burning Maga hats I'm gonna play a clip
for you here a former Arizona Republican
Senate candidate uh what was this guy's
name I don't even remember this guy's
name uh Daniel McCarthy uh yes Daniel
McCarthy he has completely turned on
Donald Trump is challenging Trump to a
debate at the Trump rally scheduled for
next Saturday calls Trump quote a little
[ __ ] and then uses a flamethrower to
burn his own Mega hat this is great this
is great and I'll tell you why in a
moment let's take a look at the video
Let's listen
hey Donald Trump this is Daniel McCarthy
in Arizona the world is waking up to
your massive grift please stop with the
smoke and mirrors with these audits stop
with your fundraising stop a
establishment candidate endorsements
stop pushing this gene therapy now I
have to stop there
YouTube has a policy where
it's not enough that my audience knows
I support and accept the science on
vaccines every time such statements are
made like the vaccines or Gene therapies
I have to rebut it every time to be in
compliance with YouTube this is what's
going on so I want to remind you guys we
have extensively debunked the notion
that the vaccines are quote Gene
therapies they are Gene based vaccines
but they are not Gene therapies that
change your genes okay I just have to
it's important I have to do that every
time I'm sorry sauce I hear you're
coming to Florence Arizona for another
one of your do-nothing raw raw session
rallies well I have an offer for you I
will give one million dollars to the
charity of your choice wow if you take
30 minutes of your stage time on January
15th and debate me or answer my
questions even in front of your crowd
think about all the things that you've
done that you've got you've not been
held accountable for you ushered in
medical tyranny that's not true Donald
Trump did not usher in any medical
tyranny you exploded our national debt
that's true he did explode the national
debt you relinquished our sovereignty
with the usmca trade deal that's untrue
usmca very similar to NAFTA quite
uncontroversial certainly did not give
up any sovereignty
as an Obama did with fixed Knicks that I
don't even know about I'm not even sure
about that one you warned about election
fraud but yet you did nothing to prevent
it even after my team months in advance
warned you after we were stolen from in
the Senate primary that's just crazy
talk that one's hard that one's there's
so many elements to that when it's hard
to even refute you gave up on
Therapeutics and you push an
experimental gene therapy and again the
vaccine is not an experimental gene
therapy
petely dying because of their trust in
you now
that's interesting people are dying
because of their trust in you there are
people dying because they believed based
on Trump that they shouldn't get the
vaccine that's not actually what Trump
said it's true people are dying because
of their trust in Trump but not for the
reason that McCarthy is saying that
that's kind of a complicated one ninth
of the lockdowns and you surrounded
yourself with swamp creatures for four
years he did surround himself with swamp
creatures Trump did not enact any
lockdowns the January 6 protesters that
came down to the Capitol you set them up
those people are being treated worse
than dogs now they so setup suggests it
was I mean Trump just encouraged them to
do what they did it wasn't really a
setup and these are your most loyal
supporters Trump you failed America yes
you're the most deceptive president in
American history that's true that's true
trust me there's been a lot of Psy outs
before I've posted the terms and
conditions of my one million dollar
offer to my website
www.demandaniel.com I look forward to
seeing you on January 15th although I
know you won't do it because you're a
little [ __ ] right
and so now he's getting out of the truck
and he's gonna flamethrow his own uh
Maga hat so the magats are revolting
and there it is
well
and then he Stomps it out
and then he drives over it with his
truck
yeah
well Trump will never talk to me because
he knows he can't because his family's
name would be tarnished forever
okay so obviously this guy's completely
out of his mind I mean completely cuckoo
for Cocoa Puffs but the fact that now
even trumpists are turning on Trump is
very interesting tomorrow we are going
to have a report about Stephanie Grisham
very briefly the press secretary for
Trump
um she says there's a group of 15
Republicans getting together to try to
preemptively neuter Trump from ever
running in 2024 so there's a very
interesting counter Trump movement even
within trumpism we're going to talk
about it you can see the clip if you
were listening to this segment you can
see the clip of this Daniel McCarthy guy
flame throwing the mega hat on our
Instagram which is David packman show on
Instagram you can also find me on
Instagram at david.pakman
science has shown us that lowering your
body temperature at night helps you
sleep I can't sleep in a hot room that's
why I love our sponsored chili sleep
which makes customizable climate
controlled sleep solutions to sleep
better their Flagship products are the
uler Sleep System and the cube sleep
system which is what I have both are
Hydro powered temperature controlled
luxury mattress pads you can make them
as cold as 55 degrees Fahrenheit if you
wanted you could go as hot as 115
degrees I like the cooler option I keep
mine at 60 degrees and it gives me a
great cool night of sleep no feeling hot
no more sweating I'm falling asleep
faster and it pairs perfectly with chili
sleeps weighted chili blanket which
keeps you cold on top too right now
chili sleep is running a special sale
you'll get 30 percent off everything
when you go to chiliesleep.com Pacman
the link is right underneath this video